à travers un tweet qui n'a pas plu à
tout le monde dimanche manif de l'Arque
républicain du RN à la macronie de Bron
pivé et sous prétexte d'antisémitisme
ramène Israël Palestine sans demander le
cesser le feu les amis du soutien
inconditionnel on massacre on
rendez-vous c'est honteux c'est vous
savez déjà de citer
C mais il y Abron PIV de citer Bron pivé
dans son twet al alors qu'en ce moment
on sait que
P ça pour moi ça ça Twitter ça BR PIV
doit elle doit doelle doit le signaler
je suis désolé elle l' signalé et on
apporte
son
Montien je dire une chose on renvoie
souvent dos ados
nos nos arguments sur le rassemblement
national et la France insoumise je pense
sincèrement monsieurou j'entends votre
appel à l'unité mais que vous vous
servez du malheur des Juifs pour mieux
développer votre discours antimusulman
et je pense que dans le même temps
Jean-Luc Mélenchon utilise la cause
palestinienne pour masquer son ambigué
et le mot est faible deux PHAs d'une
même pièce oui le mot est faible sur
l'antisémitisme et je pense que vous
êtes les deux côtés d'une même pièce et
que vous vous servez l'un l'autre voilà
mon combat aujourd'hui parce que vous
n'êtes pas dans cet arc républicain dans
lequel je mets d'autres partis
politiques je ne vous empêcherai pas de
venir dimanche je n'empêcherai jamais
encore moins même vos électeurs de venir
mais encore une fois comme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et comme une partie de ses
alliés aujourd'hui qui n'arrivent pas à
se départir de l'influence de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon tant que ses alliés n'auront
pas assumer l'erreur manifeste qu'ils
ont fait en s'alliant avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon étant que le rassemblement
national n'aura pas été plus clair et
condamnant encore une fois les propos
d'antisémite tenu par je Jean-Marie Le
Pen j'aurais du mal à défiler avec vous
et c'est même
impossible sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon juste
une chose parce qu'il faut savoir se
regarder dans la glace c'est Monsieur
Mélenchon qui a fait élire et réélire
monsieur
Macron vous la macronie c'est vous la
macronie qui avait fait élire un certain
nombre de députés de la France insoumise
qui sont aujourd'hui des porte-paroles
du Hamas à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
vous qui avez pris cette responsabilité
là donc très clairement ne nous donnez
pas
de très clairement c'est vous qui avez
porté ces gens-là encore une fois aux
responsabilités où ils sont français
enchon sur d'autres sujets il avait
pourtant aucun problème à marcher au
côté du rassemblement national sur la
réform des Rett marché avec voilà
regardez Luc Mélenchon était bien
présent hier lors de la marche contre
[Musique]
l'islamophobieé nous ne sommes pas dans
quelque obscure congrès de je ne sais
quel penseur d'avant-garde nous sommes
devant un peuple qui par millions
comportte des gens qui appartiennent à
une religion qui sont menacés et qui
mont du Doig stigmatisé tous les jours
qui ont peur et qui se demandent si ce
pays est aussi le leur moi j'ai j'ai
j'ai une question à vous poser pourquoi
on fait pas une marche contre
l'antisémitisme et l'islamophobie en
même temps parce que c'est pas la même
chose d'accord non mais c'est une
question parce que qui revient très
souvent sur les
réseaux n'est pas condamnable en France
l'islamophobie c'est pas s'en prendre
parce que a une différence
l'antisémitisme c'est s'en prendre à des
personnes pour ce qu'ils sont en
l'occurrence des Juifs l'islamophobie
c'est la critique d'une religion et en
France on a le droit critiquer toutes
les opinions religieuses c'est dans
notre Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen et je rappelle d'ailleurs
que les députés de la France insouis et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avaient participé à
une marche scandaleuse organisée par
l'officine islamiste du CCIS qui a été
dissoute en il y a quelques années je l'
je professionnel je l' mettez là était
bien présent hier lors de la marche
contre
[Musique]
l'islamophobieité nous ne sommes pas
dans obscure congrès ilettre toujours la
même mat c'était une autre que je
voulais mais bon la régie C8 est partie
21h4 forcément il sont déjà chez eux en
train de manger des des granau là euh
non non mais c'est vrai que il a il y a
plein de gens qui qui posent cette
question sur les réseaux donc je je je
je me fais le porte-parole de ce que je
vois il y a plein de gens qui disent
pourquoi on fait pas une marche pour la
paix tous ensemble euh et alors une
marche contre l'antisémitisme et eu donc
je est-ce- ce que vous en pensez est-ce
qu'il faut faire est- faut faire de
March sont deux thématiques là c'est on
parle on parle
la Moné d'
an ch pense que c'est très bien que Fr
de toute confession soi derrière les
citoyens de religion juif pour leur dire
on ne vous abandonne pas vous êtes des
enfants de la République et la
République est avec vous ça c'est un
prier une première chose et on peut
éventuellement évidemment et avec au
contraire grand grand plaisir là encore
faire une sorte d'arc républicain où
tout tout le monde serait là pour la
paix aussi alors moi je voudraisis qu'on
qu'on vienne sur le sujet de départ
Olivier Verant qui dit que le r n'a pas
sa place à cette marche dimanche Raymon
toi tu as dit que tu es pas d'accord
avec Olivier Verant moi je suis pas
d'accord avec Olivier Verant parce que
pour tous les les sujets qui ont été
dits pour tous les arguments ça divise
pourquoi il y aurait une certaine France
qui aurait le droit d'aller manifester
et pas d'autres le le moi je dis pas le
rassemblement je dis le Front national
le Front national c'est beaucoup de gens
qui votent ils sont pas tous antisémites
c'est pas vrai ils sont ils ont pas la
haine des Juifs il y a des gens qui
votent Front national c'est pas pour ça
qu'ils ont la haine des Juifs donc moi
je dis que des gens ont leur place ici
de ça au-delà ça moi ce que je trouve un
peu bon vous avez tout dit tout a été
dit c'est pas moi qui vais rajouter plus
d' d'intellectuel c'est j'aurais changé
moi je suis d'accord avec toi Cyril moi
j'aurais changé marche contre
l'antisémitisme j'aurais mis marche pour
la paix ou marche pour les otages parce
que d'un côté tu peux pas avoir un
gouvernement qui dit interdire les
manifestations palestiniennes et de
l'autre côté qui organise une marche
pour l'antisémitisme s'il avait changé
le nom s'il avait changé le nom on sera
pas en train de polémiquer je vous dis
c'est qui demande
c'est pas des gens du gouvern
paremé dans la tête des gens il a raison
vous êtes des intellectuels dans la tte
dans la tête des gens comme moi c'est
pas péjoratif mais dans la tête de
ququun c'est il y a brôle Pivet et et
leie vous avez dit là qui demande une
marche contre l'antisémitisme moi à
bruti comme je suis je me dis on aurait
changé le nom on aurait dit une marche
pour les otagees une marche pour la
p pas en de
prendre on on manifestation et on
organise lae Val exuse-moi en quoi c'est
gênant je ne comprends même pas en quoi
c'est gênant dis tu dis on s'engueule
pour une marche contre l'antisémitisme à
quel moment on doit s'engueuler pour une
marche contre le racisme c'est quand
même abrant on on marche enfin on
devient fou dans ce pays on on on est en
train de débattre de savoir si c'est
opportun de faire une marche contre le
racisme on devient
dingue j'ai vu un sondage j'ai vu un
sondage qui m'a qui m'a qui m'a rivolté
je vous dis sur les réseaux encore où je
voyais il y avait 70 % des gens qui
étaient contre cette marche sur les
parce que c'est le titre qui déconne moi
je vous le
dis président plît'il plaî s'il vous
plaîette marche contre l'antisémitisme
sont antisémites par définition je suis
désolé bien sûr que si et je pense que
vous vous trompez de cible là on a deux
personnes sur ce plateau qui veulent
aller à cette marche donc qui ne sont
pas antisémit par définition et vous
avez une personne qui refuse d'y aller
et qui est probablement antisémite c'est
lui qu'il faut condamner c'est pas ceux
qui veulent qui veulent y aller ils
combattent l'antisémitisme ceux qui
refusent d'aller à cette marche et qui
la condamn sont de fait antisémit une
encore une fois c'est pas ce que je dis
moi ce que je dis simplement c'est qu'un
parti qui fait justement de la politique
politicienne et qui veut faire
l'expression a été employée tout à
l'heure du green washing sur le dos
justement de cette nouble cause qui est
l'antisémitisme n'a pas pardon fait
preuve de dessence auparavant et n'a pas
fait la condamnation claire et puissante
de ce que ce parti a pu être dans le
passé pour être présent je leur interdis
pas d'être présent je trouve qu'ils ne
sont pas décents et je trouve que sur ce
sujet ils n'ont pas été à la hauteur et
si la communauté juive rejette mais
fortement regardez les images Marine Le
Pen en 2018 l d'une
manifestation
Mar pouri Mar Leen n'elle jamais été en
iso'z pas pourquoi vous n'avez pas r
pourquoi vous n'avez pas renvoyé dos às
le rassemblement national et la France
il y a 5 minutes je vous ai
dit il fait minut pourquoi Marine Le Pen
n--elle jamais faire un voyage en Israël
parce qu'elle a un problème elle a un
problème avec l'antisémitisme qu'elle ne
se sent pas légitime à y aller vous êtes
coprésident du groupe d'amitié France
Israël bah pourquoi c'est pas vrai
pourquoi il n va pas RT la rupture entre
Marine Le Pen et son père je pose la
question à jou pourquoi Mar Leen pas Mar
Leen et son père c'est au sujet de l'an
carrière politique pourquoi pas mais
vous vous résumer en fait le soutien à
Israël et au nos compatries de
confession Ju par on parle un peu d'isra
en ce pour
pour vousz dit c'est une double
finaliste à l'élection
présidentielle laisso termin je sais que
ça vous dérange je sais que ça vous
dérange parce
que et encore plus depuis quelques
semaines c'est que nous recevons Jordane
Bardella Marine Le Pen elle-même et nos
députés de soutien soit qui viennent
d'Israël soit des compatriotes en France
pourquoi Marine Le Pen n'at-elle jamais
été en Israël mais encore une fois vous
le savez et depuis à sonombre d'années
si elle a besoin d'abiller elle peut
demander à
[Rires]
anidalgo ou voilà donc pourquoi n
va-elle pas enfin pardon c'est simple
comme question ça fait 20 ans qu'elle
fait de la poli qu'elle pourit aller
est-elle pour mais bien évidemment et et
elle le fera quand elle le décidera mais
elle va pas se voir imposer ce voyage
par la bienpensance de monsieuror ou de
certains vous savez elle elle les juifs
avec des actes avec de la politique de
Laour vouszitelques
annéesmichich si j'ai par un peu je vais
surtoutpondre parce que
évidemment c'est une belle idée marche
pour la paix la marche pour la paix tout
le monde est pour la paix à part
quelques verre quelques G qui
sont
pas sens de faire une marche pour la
paix faire une marche contre ça un sens
par il une recresence incroyable
compr compr Mar pour la pai évidment on
est tous pour la paix c'est commeil on
est tous pour la pai alors que ce moment
en revanche en ce moment il y a un
regain odieux d'A antisémite donc il
faut se mobiliser il faut marcher pai on
peut marcher tous les jours pour
lav d'une sorte de cohésion d'union en
je sou viens qu'après le battaclan on
était combien on était 4 millions dans
les rues de Paris évidemment on sera pas
4 millions malheureusement contre
l'antisémitisme et vous disez il y a 70
personnes 70 % de de Français qui sont
contre cette marche non c'est ce que
je interpelle mais ça interpelle parce
que je pense que c'est la c'est c'est le
c'est le vrai reflet malgré tout de la
société française malheureusement qui
est complètement fracturé parce que il y
a un amalgame parce que ça n'est pas
clair parce que cette marche ça n'est
pas contre l'antisémitisme les gens
pensent que en y allant on valide
politique israélienne on Val N et il y a
cette ambigé c'est pour ça qu'il faut
clarifier faut faire de l'éducation et
vous les hommes politiques vous avez une
responsabilité voilà il faut tre très
Clairis qu'on VI sur le sujet VI sur le
sujet de départ s'il PL je suis sur le
sujet de départ moi je pense que ça dit
quelque chose d'absolument terrible sur
cette société c'est que aujourd'hui tu
dis non il faut changer le titre de
cette marche ça veut dire qu'en France
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui marcher de
façon unie et et de dire non à
l'antisémitisme c'est très grave ça veut
dire que il faut changer les intitulés
il faut faire ceci il faut faire cela
mais en fait on peut pas marcher comme
on l'a fait par le passé contre
l'antisémitisme c'est très très alors
c'est quoi juste cette histoire de manif
C on vous a dit vous pouvez venir à la
manif mais vous serez à part en fait un
cordon s pas dit c'est pas un cordon
sanitaire c'est comme une c'est un truc
VIP comme en boîte non mais c'est que
c'est mais vous vous savez nous nous on
appelle à l'unité Marine Le Pen a appelé
ses électeurs nos sympathisants nos
adhérents à venir et encore une fois
nous ce qui nous importe c'est qu'on
soit les plus nombreux c'est qu'il a un
maximum de français quel que soit leur
origine leur religion leur étiquette
politique qui manifeste pour faire bloc
parce que je pense que vu la période vu
les manifestations scandaleuses qu'on a
pu voir des slogans antisémites des
étoiles de David qui sont tagués ici et
là et je pense que nos compatriotes ont
besoin de se sentir moins seul moi j'ai
beaucoup de Juifs qui me disent on est
seul aujourd'hui on se sent seul on se
sent en insécurité s'il voit du monde
s'il voit que les Français sont réunis
main dans la main quel que soit leur
divergence je pense qu'ils sentiront
moins seul et que la République sera
conforé s'il vous plaît est-ce que vous
allez y aller qu'est-ce que quelqu'un va
y aller Valée JeanMichel g non non non
je marche pas à côté des élus du
rassemblementor il sera il marchera pas
à
cé ser il marcha cé sil PLT sil vous
plaî sil vous plaî loï il y sera il sera
pas à côté des élus du rassembl national
il y va pour la paix marche ter
contretisé mais vous me demandez si je
vous dis
non j vais pas parce que je marche pas à
côté de
monsieuré méchon
sur une manifestation qui était la
manifestation où il y avait le CCIF et
cetera on l'a interpellé là-dessus elle
a dit seul le mot d'ordre compte donc
c'est quelqu'un de la France insoumise
que tu estimes quand on te dit seul le
mot d'ordre compte là en l'occurrence le
mot d'ordre c'est la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme c'est c'est bizarre
après ronte une question moi je ne vais
pas au manif non mais juste voulais dire
un truc c'est ce qu'a dit Gill quand on
lui a dit pour tu vas au manif il a dit
je ne vais pas au manif parce que c'est
délicat pour moi d'aller au manif
souvenez là il vient de dire je n'y vais
pas parce que une raison normalement tu
dois
dire je ne ve aucune manif ni celle-là
ni une autre là tu cherches tu dis je ne
vais pas au manif parce qu'il y a le RN
et des émissions d'avant tu as dit je ne
vais pas au manif parce que je ne vais
pas au
manifpect oui 18 % non il sont pas
d'accord avec Olivier Verant non à 81 %
82% ouais le sondage là il est il est
sans app voilà merci en tout casor
d'avoir été là merci j merci à vous tout
de suite c'est sur C8 merci à vous